what's going on everyone i think one of
the best things about entrepreneurship
is the lessons that we learn from
failure right and i try and share as
many as i can
uh on this on this you know vlog podcast
etc
um because i think that if i can help
you not have the failure to learn the
lesson then you can get the lesson
without the scar
that being said one of the hardest
things is learning the right lesson from
failure
and so let me let me unpack that because
i think it's one of the most profound
things that
we as entrepreneurs or just we as people
have to learn
is making sure that we're we're getting
the right takeaway so let me give you a
couple different examples to show you
the wrong takeaways
um and then kind of maybe walk through a
framework that might be useful
so let's say uh you know you're in
middle school and you're dancing with
someone of the opposite sex or whatever
you're attracted to whatever right
you're dancing with someone you like
and uh i'll just use the guy girl
example because that's what i'm used to
so it's like let's say i'm dancing with
a girl
and uh and she she breaks my heart
whatever right
if i said ah girls aren't for me
right girls don't work right that would
be ridiculous
right of course it would be it would
just mean that that didn't work in that
one instance
but if i took the wrong lesson from it
then i might swear off women all
together
right and what's interesting is that
that's an incredibly ridiculous example
but people do it every single day right
it's like a business owner who hires an
employee and the employee doesn't work
out and says ah
employees they all suck they're not for
me
right it's learning the wrong lesson
from the failure
and so i think it's just as dangerous
maybe even more dangerous
to learn the wrong lesson because now
you have a story that you've told
yourself
that reinforces the incorrect lesson and
then from that point going forward
you you operate under this false guise
this false belief that you've told
yourself
that you believe is right because you
have experience right and just because
you have experience doesn't mean we took
the right lesson from it
and so i'll tell you one that's uh
that's been really that's been
really interesting for me to learn um is
over the last uh you know over how many
years right
i have succeeded a lot based on inbound
marketing
all right so that means paid advertising
to generate demand in
inwards right and what's interesting
about that is
a lot of my successes come from it but
what's interesting is that i think that
i've had a really long-term perspective
when it comes to
my health right health and fitness like
when i work out and how i eat
i've always tried to pick really
sustainable things that i can do forever
right and i've been in pretty good shape
for
you know almost almost 20 years um and
so that's that's been a successful
action that i've been able to repeat
over and over again
to the same degree my marriage is
actually probably one of the better
things that i've done
i picked that rationally my partner
laila
and we both said we want to go this way
we have this mission we have these
values
and we'll figure out the love stuff as
we go and we actually got married before
we were really in love
um mostly just because we thought we
were so aligned and we've learned the
love and every year it's actually gotten
better
and that was a rational decision that
was made by you know by both of us
but and it was based on long-term
thinking but what's interesting is that
i've like been able to
observe my own actions uh over the last
decade you know in business
and i actually even think that i've
still been
more short-term skewed in my thinking
because of the thing that i got really
good at which is inbound
and inbound you can immediately gen you
can snap your fingers and make money
tomorrow
and you can make a tremendous amount of
money in a very short period of time
and i think in some ways i may have
learned the wrong lesson
from my early success which is success
should come big and should come fast
right for me right because that's that's
my own it's for my own belief
and um as i look at the things that i've
done that i've done really well for a
long period of time none of them follow
that
that path right and so i've been you
know
strategically or deliberately kind of
deconstructing my beliefs around
what i think success should look like
and what growth should look like
and i'm finding myself more and more
trying to move in the direction of
sustainable growth which i remember
hearing when i was younger and being
like ah that's horse crap
but now as you know i feel like i've
gotten more scars and more experience
i actually think that if you're really
looking on an endless horizon which is
what i try to shift myself towards
then you only do things that you think
are worthwhile and your
obsession my own obsession with the
hurry and the rush
you know i would love to say disappears
but at least it decreases
right because if you're like you get
from the finite to the infinite you go
for
the can i do this until i die i know
that what i do in fitness i can do until
i die i know that
you know the way that layla and i run
our marriage i can do till i die like
the way that we we've we've we've done
this we can do so i don't know you might
be like oh you've only been married for
five years sure
maybe yeah maybe like maybe maybe i'll
have to keep saying this and then it's
like you've only been married 10 years
only been married 20 years
i don't know we'll see right but it
feels the same long-term way
the way the other ones did because we
have there's way less volatility
it's just a slow and steady progress and
so when i think about what i
like how i'm trying to build things now
it's different right
uh in the beginning it was just like
short hard fast like let's go let's go
let's go
um and i feel like now as i've gotten
more experienced or more weathered
it's more like okay this is our current
growth rate can we just sustain this
right because if we if we can just
sustain this for 10 years
we'll be at 100 million plus we'll be at
200 million plus if we just
do this and what that's forced me to do
is
is increase the time between my thoughts
and my actions
which entrepreneurship is so interesting
because you have to kind of unlearn some
of the things that got you started in
the beginning you can't do anything
because you're so paralyzed so
you do need to decrease some of the time
because you start taking action right
but at a certain point you start
becoming so good at taking action that
you end up breaking things
right so you actually have to start
increasing that time and what that does
is it gives you more space to make
decisions that are in a
that are rational instead of emotional
and so that's when you see a competitor
run an ad or you see
an employee leave with clients or
whatever happens and you want to have
some reaction
and most times no reaction is the best
decision
and this is just like it's been this
repeated trend that i've had
and so my current the current lesson
that i'm trying to see
is is actually not from failure but
making sure that i learned the correct
lesson from my success
um and thinking it might have actually
been bad for me
that i was that i was so successful so
early on
uh and it might have been that i took
the wrong strategy from it
and so what i the things that i'm trying
to build now are far more enduring
uh and more stable and do not require me
or my skill
at all and by doing that i feel like i'm
getting closer to the first time in my
life where i actually have businesses
that truly run without me um like
actually
not as in like oh i don't do the day to
day that's definitely one level and one
component of it
but when it can get to the point where
it truly grows without me
and i'm really just there to guide
direction and be a sounding board for
the leadership team that's in place i
feel like that's that's where
i should go um and i feel like the
things that i'm building now
are in alignment with that and it's been
it's taken years to get here
um and so anywho my goal is
if you are if you are in it and you're
not growing as
as fast as you want but you are growing
then extrapolate that over 10 years
right extrapolate over five years and
say can i just grow at
10 every every every quarter that's huge
growth
right can i just do this every quarter
can i just make this sustainable can i
make this consistent because
what i'm seeing is the richest people in
the world just look for
reliability they look for low volatility
which means less of this
and so if i can decrease the volatility
of the business by making things more
consistent
and not going for the big the big win
that's like right there right
and i just stay patient um it continues
to pay dividends and so that's kind of
the chapter that i'm in right now um in
the lesson that i'm trying to learn or
or walk uh and so i figured i would just
share that with you
and also just the thought process around
looking at your successes and your
failures and making sure that you learn
the right lessons from them
because i've definitely taken lessons
from my successes that
that were not that were not correct and
i've taken lessons from my failures that
were not correct
and each each of them is equally dooming
or damning
right and a fun final thought that i'll
leave you with
is what if everything that you did when
you were successful was not because of
you but because of outside forces
and everything that you've done to fail
was your fault
i've taken this perspective and tried to
apply it to my life and i've had an
amazing amount of
inferences and thoughts that have gone
around it that have been completely new
so it's like what if what if when you
were successful that one time maybe it
wasn't because of you at all maybe it
was just
maybe it was just chance right maybe
it's just coincidence
and i think a lot of times we apply
those frameworks to other people but
never to ourselves so someone does
something bad we say it's their fault
something good happens if we don't like
them
we're like oh that was because they got
luckier only because of this outside
circumstance that wasn't because of them
but we never apply that to ourselves and
i think that if we do if you reverse it
because we always want to say we take
credit for our
for our wins and we say our losses are
because of outside circumstances but if
we flip that
a lot of times i think you get some
really interesting lessons that can come
from it
and just just walking through the
thought process what if this wasn't
because of me
what other things happened that didn't
line up for me
that were not my doing and by doing that
you'll start to
you'll start to see different trends and
different patterns then maybe you cannot
you can
you can take advantage of opportunities
when they aren't because of you but you
can still
take advantage right and so anyways i
wanted to share this thought process
with you
for me it's been incredibly valuable um
and i hope it is valuable for you too
so uh enjoy and i'll see in the next
[Music]
[Applause]
you